COMPETITION.
>> IT’S A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THE THEY
PLAN TO DO NEXT.
>> Tucker: THEN THERE’S A
PRICE FOR THE MOST VULGAR
GRAFFITI SPRAY PAINTED ON THE
STOREFRONT, EXTRA POINTS ON
SIZE.
IF YOU WANT TO PARTICIPATE,
EXPECT FIERCE COMPETITION.
UNLIKE THE ACTUAL OLYMPICS THERE
WILL BE ABSOLUTELY NO DRUG
TESTING OF ANY KIND AND WE CAN
PROMISE YOU THAT.
SO WHAT OTHER EVENTS SHOULD THE
PEOPLE INCLUDE IN THEIR FIRST
GAMES?
FOR THAT WE TURN TO AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST MARK STEYN.
IT’S GREAT TO SEE YOU, I ASSUME
YOU WILL BE COMPETING?
>> WELL I WILL CERTAINLY BE
FOLLOWING IT.
YOU MENTIONED THAT THE DOPE
TESTING, THAT’S NOT ACTUALLY
GOING TO WELL AT THE MOMENT.
AFTER A COUPLE OF WEEKS OF
LIVING OUT OF THE STREETS OF
CHOP, MANY OF THE TOP PERFORMERS
ARE IN A BIT OF A BIND BECAUSE
TRACES OF HAVE BEEN FOUND IN THE
DRUG SAMPLES SO THAT’S ACTUALLY
A BIT OF A PROBLEM.
MITT ROMNEY WHO AS YOU KNOW IT
IS THE FIRST AMBASSADOR, AND AS
YOU KNOW HE RAN THE WINTER
OLYMPICS.
HE HAD A COUPLE OF THE TOP
WINTER OLYMPIC SPORTS INTO THE
SUMMER GAMES.
THERE IS A BIT OF A DIFFERENCE.
THE GUY ON THE BOTTOM IS ONE OF
THE CHOP RESIDENCE, BUT THE GUY
ON TOP IS ACTUALLY A STATUE OF
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS THAT
THEY’VE TOPPLED IT.
SO FOR THE PRELIMINARY ROUNDS I
BELIEVE IT’S THE RICHMOND
VIRGINIA CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS
STATUE THAT IS IN THE LEAD.
THE BOSTON CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS
STATUE IS CLOSE BEHIND BUT THERE
ARE SOME TECHNICAL DISPUTE WITH
THE JUDGES BECAUSE LIKE I HAD TO
HIS HEAD DECAPITATED AND IT’S
NOT CLEAR WHETHER A HEADLESS
CHRISTOPHER COLUMBUS IS ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR THE TWO MAN LOOTERS
LOOTERS.
HE WILL ALSO BE PERSONALLY
JUDGING THE ICE DANCING.
THIS IS WHERE CITIZENS WHO WERE
FORMERLY UNDOCUMENTED AMERICANS
PUT ON THE SPANGLISH BOLERO
JACKET AND THEY DANCE AROUND
I.C.E. AGENTS AND ODDLY ENOUGH
THEY ALL SKATE EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE SCHEDULED FOR DEPORTATION.
A LOT OF INTERESTING NEW SPORTS
OF THE TOP SUMMER GAMES.
HE ADMITS HE’S ACTUALLY GOING TO
PERSONALLY BRING THE BLAZING
OLYMPIC TORCH FROM THE NEAREST
FLAMING WINDOWS.
IT WILL BE CARRIED FROM WENDY’S
TO WENDY’S TO WENDY’S, ONE
FLAMING WENDY’S TO ANOTHER.